en el vídeo pasado sentamos las bases
intuitivas de por qué o más bien qué es
lo que representa una serie de mclaren y
hacia el final del vídeo les dije que la
serie de mac loring es un caso especial
de la serie de tale of en la serie de
mac lorin estamos aproximando la función
alrededor de x igual a 0 en la serie de
taylor de la cual les hablaré en un
vídeo posterior
tú puedes aproximar el valor de la
función alrededor de una x arbitraria o
más bien de una f x arbitraria con eso
en mente enfoquémonos en la serie de
mack loring que es bastante más simple y
nos puede llevar a conclusiones
profundas acerca de las matemáticas que
es exactamente a donde quiero llegar
hagamos entonces la sedema cloning para
funciones que son fácil de tomar
derivadas y de las cuales puedes tomar
derivadas una vez y otra vez y otra vez
y nunca terminar de hacerlo así que
desarrollamos la serie de mclaren para
coseno de x
tomamos fx igual a kossen de equis y
antes de que apliquemos esta fórmula que
desarrollamos de manera intuitiva en el
vídeo pasado tomemos algunas derivadas
para que nos demos una idea de cómo se
comportan así es que si tomamos la
primera derivada f prima de x arriba de
coseno de x es menos seno de x tomemos
sola la derivada de esta primera
derivada
efe mi prima de x leyva de seno de x es
con x pero con el signo menos es menos
coseno de x tomemos la segunda derivada
rival coseno de x es menos en x pero con
este signo menos nos da seno de x
positivo y si tomamos la derivada de eso
tendremos la diva el seno de x que es
pues en el x sería la cuarta derivada
usar esta anotación para la cuarta
derivada entonces es coseno de x la
cuarta derivada y si ves la fórmula que
desarrollamos en el vídeo pasado
necesitamos tanto la función evaluada en
0 como sus derivadas evaluadas en cero
así es que calculemos estos valores
efe de cero
efe de 0 es igual a coseno de 0 coseno
de cero es 1 2 en odesur es uno sin
importar si estás hablando de 0 grados o
0 radian es seno de 0 es cero seno de
cero es cero entonces tenemos f prima
efe prima de 0 es igual a cero jose no
de cero es 1
como tenemos el signo menos entonces
sería menos 1 la segunda derivada
evaluada en 0 es igual a menos 1 tomemos
ahora la tercera derivada la tercera
derivada de evaluada en cero es seno de
cero y seno de cero es igual a cero
vamos a la cuarta derivada coseno de
cero es 1 la f4 y prima de 0 es igual a
1 y aquí vemos un patrón interesante 10
menos 10 10 menos 10
así es que si aplicamos esta fórmula con
estos valores que lo que resultaría
déjame hacer mi mejor labor aquí
tendríamos que así que nuestro polinomio
nuestra aproximación polinomio de coste
de x sería efe de 0 efe de 0 es igual a
1 más
efe prima en 0 1 + efe primer 0
pero efe prima de 0 es igual a 0
entonces efe primer 0 por x sería 0 y
siquiera nos vamos a tomar la molestia
de escribirlo este segundo término el
cual es 0 + la segunda derivada evaluada
en 0 la segunda derivada de valor en 0
que es menos 1 entonces sería menos -1
por x cuadrada sobre 2 factorial 2
factoriales 2 pero vamos a escribirlo
aquí como 2 factorial para ver el patrón
para que sea más evidente el patrón que
se forma vamos al siguiente término el
siguiente término es la tercera derivada
evaluada en 0 pero la tercera derivada
del valor en cero también es cero así es
que este término también desaparece de
la expresión veamos el siguiente término
es la 4ª derivada de evaluada en cero
este término es igual a 1 por lo cual
aquí este coeficiente es 1
uno que multiplica a x 4a sobre 4
factorial y aquí ya podemos ver que
empieza a surgir un patrón tenemos un
cambio de signos un signo positivo
de 1 negativo luego 1 positivo y esto lo
puedes checar conforme aumentamos
términos a la serie puedes hacer esto si
no me crees aquí el término es x a la 01
por x a la 0 - x cuadrada + x a la
cuarta y de acuerdo este patrón si aquí
tenemos un signo más seguido un signo
menos x a las 6 sobre 6 factorial lo
vendría más x a la octava sobre 8
factorial menos x a la décima sobre 10
factorial y así puede seguir
sucesivamente y si continuamos agregando
términos lo que tenemos aquí es la
expansión polinomio de coseno de x y
realmente es muy padre que podamos
representar así una función
trigonométricas es un patrón muy simple
para una función trigonométricas nos
volvemos a encontrar con que todo en
matemáticas está conectado y en futuros
vídeos veremos conexiones tan profundas
que ni te imaginas